[Music]
oh okay
what's up
foreign
okay having the seat in the seat here
put them in the air conditioning
sweetheart
hey darling hi sweetie baby girl
hey hi
what's this huh
there you go there you go sweetheart
okay you're okay you're okay sweetheart
you're okay
good freaking spot boys good spot you're
okay sweetheart you're okay
you're okay baby girl
good good spot man
you're okay darling you're okay
you're doing great sweetheart you're
doing great you're doing so good
with the baby left in the car with the
door locked oh God so baby was
overheating in the car they took it out
and put hot put cold water
yeah so she's overheated
uh we're gonna take the straight Jones